what is going on there citizens of the reject
nation we got ourselves a trailer for werewolf
by night right now just want to give a heads up
our secret invasion trailer blocked everyone's
getting blocked right now i'm sure disney will
eventually be like maybe we shouldn't be blocking
this and there's nothing really dude what are you
going to watch a reaction with no audio no visuals
you can't do that but anyway guys andrew how are
you i'm doing well john never better now i'm not
that familiar with werewolf by night but andrew's
pretty well versed in it right now how are you
good you mean first and foremost i know i
know about where we'll find out yes jack
russell what's this these are mr technical over
here all right let's get to it leave a like
this halloween you can't escape oh my god
werewolf by night oh my god that's awesome
it is every hunter for themselves there
is good luck i'll be rotting for you
one of you is my monster
masquerading as one of our own i can't wait
to find out what breed of evil you are oh
i love it oh my god
please don't do this is coming for you
is that oh is it a man thing
are they really doing this
this feels like something you'd want marvel to
do but would never do straight out of the 30s and
40s oh i'm in love that was incredible i finally
know what love is that was absolutely incredible
thanks marvel that was visually stimulating oh my
goodness gracious oh like creature feature classic
universal monster horror with that grind
house b touch to it it felt actually like
a little horrific at times with cheesy and
k oh my god i was not expecting that is the
most horror marvel's ever felt and it's so fun and
michael you got who's michael jacino yeah michael
giachino directed this right yeah oh my god i
love this yeah even if it was just like some
fan-made trailer like if they were to do werewolf
by night here's what it would be i feel like
man i love that trailer this is so so refreshing
so refreshing andrew what's where we'll find out
uh so werewolf by night is uh we see jacob russoff
but he is now known as jack russell and basically
he's a character of circumstance there's a family
uh history or basically it's a family curse
that happened from this great great great great
grandfather he was bitten by a werewolf and now
uh his gra i believe it was his grandfather was
uh read uh from the dark hold and unleashed their
family curse of uh the werewolf and now that's
why uh jacob or jack russell rather has it and
yeah no it's uh gonna be interesting i'm hoping
to that i believe it's what is it gail garcia
um what's the actual bernal yes i loved
him so much in coco he really embodied
uh that character hector and just gave him so
much humanity so i'm really curious to see him
as jack russell i know we obviously didn't get to
see any of him in this trailer it was a teaser but
i'm really looking forward to seeing him as
jack russell because again jack russell is
such a character of such a victim of circumstance
so i think that you know gael can really bring
that because he brought that to me at least from
hector just the humanity he brought to that so
really looking forward to that i'm hoping that
this show if it's really popular can we we can
get some maybe uh at some point we can see like
maybe a formation of the legion of monsters which
is a group of uh four characters that we get we
get morbius we get ghost writers yeah one man
thing i think there is a flat like you see that
like icky looking snoot and one of those flashes
i'm pretty sure that he pops up in here somewhere
oh nice yeah but it's gonna it's interesting they
got michael jacquino i mean i love his his uh
his scores that he does in all his films he's
phenomenal i love the batman coco up all those
films and it's really interesting to see him
and gael uh come back together because obviously
they have a rapport from what they did in coco
obviously you know with all the music that they
did together so i'm really curious to see how they
work together from a director to actor point of
view now so ah all right john yeah this is exactly
110 percent up my alley and i think ayo garcia
bernal has a really perfect look for the era
and the type of film style they're going for you
know he has i don't know just something that feels
right at home in a sort of gothic but also b grind
house uh you know yeah lycanthropy story and i
love that you have yeah it's just these mixing
tones it almost feels like a house on haunted
hills scenario you've got all these like hunters
gathered together and i love that idea of the
you know the hunted hiding among the hunters
trying to pass himself off as one of them and uh
and it's great that you should mention morbius
in the sony universe because this is a literal
game of werewolf thing going on on screen which i
think is really funny and charming and now i just
want to see how they you know carry this tone
over the whole special because you know i mean
as as a trailer i feel like you can sometimes lean
more heavily into like hey hey we're getting you
know sort of very very stylized in this particular
time and setting and it makes me wonder what the
breathing room of this is is gonna feel like
watching grindhouse or is it gonna step back a
little bit with the style when we actually get to
see the special itself but just the the portents
of this are really engrossing and engaging and
if there are like it seems like yeah they're
you know you'll have the world by night uh sort
of you know being hunted situation already but
then you have these other characters like a man
thing or whoever else that might show up so yeah
i'm wondering what kind of monstrous threats this
will introduce to the mcu i mean this phase we've
gotten kind of used to things not directly having
major connectivity but uh especially with blade
and other things coming up i feel like this can
easily help to expand the hellish and the horrific
side of the mcu in a way that yeah is also just
like perfect fun for halloween time and yeah this
easily shot up i was already anticipating it
just based on who the character is alone but
seeing this and seeing them be really embracing
of that style and aesthetic is just so much fun
and i love that the mcu that they're trying to do
something a little bit different you know with the
supernatural they're really you know leaning
towards you know dark gritty and scary i mean
yeah we got a little bit of taste of that
multiverse of madness with scarlet witch
and we've gotten little bits of uh in other mcu
films but really like focusing on a series that
delves deep into something that they really
haven't explored in the uh other things with
the mcu i'm really looking forward to that i
mean this looked like nothing we've seen in the
mcu from tone from a tone perspective so yeah i
thought it was perfect that was absolutely perfect
it actually i'm surprised that when you hear
michael giaccino honestly my my first thought was
it's probably going to be like as by the numbers
as you'd expect so when i saw this commitment to
the flare and the style i was very much impressed
by it and it looks like it could even get like
a little violent and uh because it's black and
white they might feel like they can get away with
a little more yeah you know it better be violent i
mean this character is a savage so i hope so yeah
yeah i liked it a lot i was i'm very much
dazzled by that i cannot wait to watch that
that was awesome um i hope it's not annoying
though uh because that is the thing you would
bring it up like it could be it's probably
just a little too indulgent with its style
that the scenes can get annoying but because
that's a problem with sometimes when you try to
ape a certain type of time period but i don't
know i feel like they might reel him back on
certain moments being noticed it still doesn't
feel like a good story we're telling you yeah
it's a connected [__] so yeah make it a good
good thing um but yeah guys uh thank you for
being here uh hopefully you get that secret
invasion video blocked unblocked i mean i am
looking at four uploads right now over there that
are all blocked can't get it up but uh we'll see